驚くことに
今年ももう終わりです、2016年もお疲れ様でした
今年から動画を見始めた方も
昔から見てくださる方も
いつも動画を見てくださり
コメントをしてくださって
応援してくださって
本当にありがとうございます
皆さま2016年いかがだったでしょうか
僕の今年はですねちょっと去年とはだいぶ変わりまして
まぁまぁまぁまぁ　大学が終わったということで
カリスマニート
ではありません
YouTubeにもっと力を入れる年だと思ってたんですけども
今年はねそんな動画に力を入れるような年ではなかったですね
あー手抜いてたってわけじゃないですよ
手を抜いてたわけではないんですけども
動画というよりかイベントとか
動画以外のところに結構力を入れることが多かったです
なので、なかなか忙しい年でしたね
うん
うんw
まあなんだろなー
動画以外でなにか色んなことに挑戦できた年かなと思いました
で、U-FESとかもあって全国いろんなとこ回りました
東北とか九州とかはね行ったことなかったんですよ
初めて行った所で
普段絶対動画作ってるだけじゃ会えないなっていう方と
実際に会うことができたりして
とてもいい1年になりました
やっぱ今年の動画全部見返すとねこうなんか色々思い出しちゃいました
今年のはじめしゃちょーはこんな感じでした
どうぞ！
うわあ！！
ｷｬｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱ
お菓子を食べません！
トミライオン：シャクシャクシャクー
はじめ：ト、トミックさん？！
聴こえる！
JUNJUN:あ、いてっ
しっかり買う物確かめてから買いましょう
ウソでしたーーー
エロサイトエロサイト～
2!1!
いきまーす！！
よっしゃーー！！
頑張るんだぞ！
はい
あったあったやった！
トミトミ：何？！
トミトミ：何これ！！？？
はじめ：いつから言葉を
New 3DS:知らないわ、気が付いたら自分でパカパカで（カット
こんにちは！はじめです！
こんにちは！とみおです！
も～～出会い厨
許さん！
SP:銃声音！
指スマ111
10人集まってくださいました、ありがとうございます
（走る俺）
（困惑するまさき）
まさき：早く警察呼ぼう
女子：これかかってますか？
はじめ：かかってるよ、バッチリかかってるよ
出来ました
キメラテックブルーワイバーン
（おしまい）
弟：もしも～し？
お～すごい
デュエルだ！
待って、ほんとに浮いてるよ
パイナッポー
え、めっちゃ可愛くないすか？
あﾝやばいかも
1年でこれだけの炭酸水を飲みましたー
ところざわ：ダメだ！
佐竹：なんでですか？
ところざわ：ポジションが被ってしまう
勝った..
やった！
というわけでこんな髪型にしてみました
では作ってくよー
3年間留学に行ってきます
やったーーー
どう？どう？
ひきこもりの鷹　ハジメだ
あっつ！
うわ！まさき！燃え
いてっいたあああ
火事だあああ
待って、やばいやばい浮いてる！
魚之骨　苦手丸
おらーーー
え、笑ってるの？
6000円でしたー
部屋の4分の1くらいなくなっちゃったｗ
よく大きくなったよこんなに
俺のアカネに手出したろ
友達になれない
なんっごめんね
はいというわけで2016年のはじめしゃちょーいかがだったでしょうか
あの..正直ちょっと悔しい年でした
動画外で色々頑張れた分ですね、ちょっと
その、、忙しかったりして
メインチャンネルに全力投球みたいな感じにできなかったので
本当はねもっと色んなことしたいんですよ
色んな動画作りたかったんですけど
色々時間とか東京に行くことも多くてあんまりそれできなかったので
来年は
来年になったら考えます
僕イベントとかで色んなステージに立たせていただいて思ったことは
僕は喋るキャラではありません
僕、喋るのあんま好きじゃないんすよ
喋るのあんま好きじゃないんで
僕はこうやってねお家でカメラに向かっておしゃべりして
それを編集したりして
やっぱ僕はね動画を作る人間なのかなっということが思いました
2017年は色んな動画作れたらいいなと思っております
（頑張れ！！）
また来年も
はじめしゃちょー
よろしくお願いします
じゃあな！
黒髪評判いいんだよなー